I was just thinking about how,
like, in LA,
how quickly people
will get on the bandwagon,
like, I tell people,
"Oh, there's an event, be here."
How quickly they go to do that.
And I don't...
understand why, like...
people have a harder time doing that
in terms of when it comes to the earth.
They're going to go.
Hi, I'm Lana Condor
and I'm in the Maasai Mara
with Netflix's Our Planet.
-Hello.
-Hi.
It's a mad, mad world here.
We landed.
There's some zebra right over here.
-There's some...
-No!
Whatever the hell those are.
The Mara is one of the places in Africa
that has the most wildlife.
They're standing up on there,
back a little.
Oh, my gosh. No way.
Is that a hippo?
There's little bubbles coming up.
Right there.
Like, way down there.
Like, right the way down, yeah.
Oh, my God.
Wait, how long
have we been here, 15 minutes?
So, it was, like... I was, like,
literally touched down in the Mara
for, like, the first ten minutes,
and I'm already watching
these lions feed on this buffalo.
Plus, they're not just lions
that are there...
It's hyenas...
And there are jackals there.
I was blown away because the buffalo
provided for all of them.
Amazing.
OK.
We just got put in our tents,
right out here is the river.
There are four hippos right here.
It is unbelievable.
Well, being out here really, like,
changes the way that you see things.
Hello, baby.
Oh, my God.
Holy... shit.
Holy shit. Holy shit.
You're OK.
Oh, my God. He's up.
He's up, he's up!
-He's up.
-He's up!
-Yes!
Oh, down.
So, I'm seeing the mom eat her placenta
and the baby find her milk
for the first time.
You got it. Good job.
Get out of the way.
This baby's, like, "I'm stressed."
Where's the...
Are we going to see the leopard?
We're going to see a leopard?
Oh, wow.
He's looking straight at us.
Yeah.
I feel like this is one of
the first animals that we've seen
that notice us.
Or at least acknowledge us.
But I was thinking...
I was thinking, like,
how quickly... everyone, like,
got in their cars and drove...
so quickly to see...
How quickly people got in
their cars to see the leopard,
and then I was just thinking
about how, like...
the earth just seems so big.
So, maybe that's why we think
that it's really hard,
'cause it's like...
It's so big that we can't even
wrap our head around the problem.
And I can grasp...
I can understand that
a little bit better.
Animals and the people
who live here need space.
And when people keep
taking it away or things change...
it makes me sad because I feel like...
there's... there's room for everyone.
Oh, look at her!
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, my gosh. Wow.
That was the trip.
That was so amazing.
Now that I've been here
for three and a half days,
I can honestly say that it truly is
a life changing experience.
We saw a lot of babies,
and then we saw a lot of big things.
But it terms of our planet,
you really kind of understand
that whole circle of life.
And you learn we're out here to coexist.
We're not out here to dominate.
Or else this beauty will go away.
This is the closest I've ever felt,
to have my feet on the ground
and be grounded
and as a part of our planet earth.
Look at this!
It's a full rainbow!
This is everyone's home,
and we must protect it.